un paso más cerca de la ruptura
definitiva con el yugo colonial
británico barbados eligió
democráticamente a su primera presidenta
sandra masón quien reemplazará a la
reina isabel segunda de reino unido como
jefas de estado cuando juramente el
cargo el próximo 30 de noviembre y el
pequeño territorio caribeño se
convertirá en república
les agradezco que me confieren el honor
de ser la primera voz desde este
privilegiado hemiciclo para felicitar a
nuestra primera presidente electa de
nuestra república que pronto será
convocada por republic
y también conocida como la pequeña
inglaterra barbados fue la colonia más
rica y productiva del caribe debido a la
explotación de azúcar y esclavos
procedentes de áfrica en 1966 logró su
independencia por la vía pacífica ahora
la isla está a punto de seguir los pasos
de otras ex colonias británicas
caribeñas que rompieron con la monarquía
británica como guyana trinidad y tobago
o dominica saben que habiendo alcanzado
nuestra independencia hace más de medio
siglo entonces el país no puede dudar de
su capacidad de autogobierno y
discapacitantes
los barbadenses quieren un jefe estado
barbadense esta es la última declaración
de confianza en lo que somos y en lo que
somos capaces de lograr
con una población de menos de 300.000
habitantes es una de las islas más
prósperas del caribe y también un
conocido paraíso fiscal pero de turistas
por la pandemia y la amenaza del cambio
climático son algunos de los retos que
tendrá que afrontar la nueva mandataria